[Applause]
lately the word brexit has become a
synonym for apocalypse for most of media
at least the media outside of the UK
there are many things to be said about
this but today we're going to focus on
this goldman sachs to move hundreds of
its staff out of london and this is just
one example that the time we're making
this video 20 banks have already
announced they will move part of their
staff out of the UK the most optimistic
estimations claim that the City of
London might lose over 30,000 workers
and the most pessimistic argue that this
could be as high as 200 thousands but
wait just a minute I mean why is this
important well if you've been following
visual politic for a while you already
know that London is the global financial
capital more specifically that global
financial capital would be the City of
London also known as the square mile the
square mile is essentially a city inside
of a city where most of the
international banks have their
headquarters
yes even after brexit it is possible
that London will keep its way on the
markets in Asia and even America but so
far European business accounts for 35%
of the city's workload and of course
leaving the European Union is going to
have some consequences
well now you might be wondering well
where are these banks gonna go which
city will be the new financial capital
after London
well after months of competition it does
seem as if we do finally have a winner
banks and other companies plan expansion
in Frankfort after brexit so far it
looks as if Frankfort is going to become
the new financial powerhouse in Europe
and perhaps one of the most important in
the entire world but what does Frankfort
have that other cities like Madrid or
Paris don't well today we are going to
answer this question but before we do
let's have a look back at the history
why are banks leaving the city the City
of London is an area about a square mile
see where the name comes from which is
located inside broader London they have
their own laws they have their own mayor
they even have their own police this
little space is the home for the main
international banks three hundred
thousand people work here and of this
three hundred thousand 60,000 are
European immigrants who entered the
country thanks to being part of the
European Union and okay my dear
countrymen I know what you're thinking
despite being an EU country that UK
never was really inside the free
circulation area
this means that theoretically the
British government could have closed the
borders to all those immigrants of any
time they wanted but in practice
European citizens were getting in and
out of the country as they pleased it's
clear that EU migration to the UK has
increased significantly over the last
two decades in 2015 there were just over
three million people living in the UK
who were born in other EU countries an
increase of about 1.9 million since 2003
nevertheless things they are going to
change order questions to the Prime
Minister the British prime minister
Conservative Theresa May holds an
extremely weak position
this is despite the fact that she won
the general election in June she just
lost a large number of seats in
parliament doing math in fact it's not
even clear if she's gonna finish our
turn and of course people from in and
out of a party they are pushing her to
increase immigration controls I've
consistently said that the referendum
vote was a vote for us to change that
freedom of movement was a vote for us to
bring control into our immigration
system for people coming from the
European Union there's a variety of ways
in which that can be done this would
have a big impact in the city of London
indeed a bigger impact than anywhere
else in the UK as we said in another
video part of London's success comes
from their ability to attract talent
from all over the world but if the
government closes its doors to
foreigners those banks who hire
immigrants will have it as significantly
harder than before and make no mistake
this is not only due to praxis in fact
the anti-immigrant sentiment in the UK
it's been going well beyond the borders
of the European Union
[Music]
Teresa may to charge companies two
thousand pounds per year for each non
European Union worker they employ but
wait a minute because there's still more
as I said Teresa may and her
Conservative Party have lost a good
share of the seats in parliament and
well where did those seats go well they
went to the Labor Party a party whose
leader Jeremy Corbyn
has declared war on the backs on his
election manifesto he already proposed
things like of this Labour called
through UK financial transaction tax
until now this tax was one of the
biggest advantages the UK had over the
EU as you might know Brussels has been
for years debating the possibility of
having a financial transaction tax this
is something bankers really don't want
and no one really wants to pay but if
the UK's parliament ends up passing such
a law a lot of companies will be
wondering if they still want to keep
their offices in London in other words
even if the brexit negotiations end up
being great for the UK's interests the
air is still becoming more and more
poisonous for the UK's financial
industry and this explains why so many
banks are starting to think about
opening offices outside of the UK
but now the question is why are they
choosing Frankfurt well let's have a
look at that
[Applause]
Europe's financial capital on the very
day after the brexit referendum the race
to take over London as the global
financial capital started for example in
Spain the regional governments of Madrid
launched their own advertising campaign
designed to attract bangers
even the finance minister Louise Dugan
does help personal meetings with
executives from JPMorgan and elsewhere
to offer special tax conditions in Paris
Emmanuel macron had already announced
lower taxes for banks in order to lure
them from London but I'm sorry guys it's
really hard to beat the Indira Frankfurt
[Applause]
Standard Chartered plc Nomura Holdings
Inc and Daiwa securities Group Inc have
all picked Germany's financial capital
for their EU base to ensure continued
access to the single market which we
want to still work through Twitter if
you slipped upon balls and clock foot
city grouping Goldman Sachs group and
Morgan Stanley are weighing a similar
decision but what's so special about
this city well first of all Frankfurt
already has the headquarters of the
European Central Bank as well as other
big banks like Deutsche Bank this means
that they already have the network
effects we always mention here official
politic they have lots of other things
like startups law firms consultancy etc
besides Frankfurt has many business
schools with international prestige as
well as a university and the
second-biggest airport in Europe you now
have in Frankfurt like foreign that
Chinese companies we have like a tonne
Turkish companies 1000 companies from
the United States only the rate of the
English companies is quite little but
this will change from my point of view
automatically if this was not enough 70%
of the German population speak English
fluently this means those British banks
can send their managers to Frankfurt
hold international meetings and even
hire locals without having to worry
about language if you think this is not
important good luck trying to find the
same setup in France where only 39
percent of the population speaks
Shakespeare's language not to mention
Spain where this percentage is lower
than 25%
but hold on a minute because there is
still more as I said in a previous video
Germany is a decentralized country
this means regional governments and
trade unions have way more autonomy here
than they have in any other country
thanks to this political architecture
the region of Hessen where Frankfurt is
other cases can offer things like this
labor laws make it difficult to fire
people
Frankfurt had initially proposed a
change in labor laws that would either
exempt bankers or high income earners
more generally from the rules okay but
now let's think about something else if
you have a bank and you want to set up
your offices somewhere what is the first
thing you will need well that would be a
building you need a physical place where
you can put your offices well in this
regard Frankfurt is better suited than
anywhere else you see after world war ii
you frankfurt it was totally destroyed
and they had to rebuild it almost from
nothing in other German cities urban
laws forbid the building of skyscrapers
in order to maintain the uniform more
traditional skyline but not in Frankfurt
here you can make buildings as high as
what
[Music]
this explains why despite a population
of less than 1 million inhabitants
Frankfurt looks like a big metropolis
further Germany as one of the cheapest
real estate markets in all of Europe
despite the high salaries houses rents
and square meters are half the price of
Paris and a fraction of the cost of
London
okay okay but now I know what you're
thinking I mean come on Simon what about
corporate tax isn't this the most
important thing of all well yeah I know
Germany has a corporate tax that in some
cases reaches 30% by comparison the UK's
at 20 and you're absolutely right but
the devil here it's really in the
details
do you ever how I said that Germany is
highly decentralized well this applies
to corporate tax too in this country
corporate tax it's divided into two
parts a national and a regional one this
means that the federal government gets
only 15% of the tax the rest depends on
the region
this means technically the state of
Hesse on where Frankfurt is really has
the ability to reduce this tax a lot and
of course doing this might endure more
and more British bankers there and
finally if none of this was enough for
you here comes the big finale the
financial transaction tax this was the
tax that we mentioned before that scares
away so many bankers that tax at least
in Europe has about as many loopholes as
possible there are so many exceptions on
this tax that even its biggest supporter
the German Finance Minister had this to
say even as Swiss cheese needs more than
holes there has to be something in
between them otherwise it's just a hole
not a Swiss cheese Wolfgang schäuble
so now we have a question for you
imagine you are the manager of one of
these London banks what would you do
would you remain in London or perhaps
would you move your offices to Frankfurt
well do let us know in the comments
below meanwhile if you want to learn
more about how London became such a
financial powerhouse do click on this
other video also remember to visit
reconsider Mediacom the podcast that
provided the vocals in this video that
are not mine and don't forget we publish
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
and you will not miss any post and if
you like this video give us a thumbs up
and as always I'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear more of my lovely voice don't
forget to check out the reconsidered
podcast at reconsider Mediacom we
consider is a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your reviews by
providing context but we don't do that
thinking for you